one of the most amazing facts in physics
is this everything in the universe from
light to electrons to atoms behaves like
both a particle and a wave at the same
time all of the other weird stuff you
might have heard about quantum physics
Schrodinger's cat God playing dice
spooky action at a distance
all of it follows directly from the fact
that everything has both particle and
wave nature this might sound crazy if
you look around you'll see waves in
water and particles of rock and they're
nothing alike so why would you think to
combine them physicists didn't just
decide to mash these things together out
of nowhere rather they were led to the
dual nature of the universe through a
process of small steps fitting together
lots of bits of evidence like pieces in
a puzzle the first person to seriously
suggest the dual nature of light was
Albert Einstein in 1905 but he was
picking up an earlier idea from Mocs
plonk clonk explained the colours of
light emitted by hot objects like the
filament in a light bulb but to do it he
needed a desperate trick he said the
object was made up of oscillators that
could only emit light in discrete chunks
units of energy that depend on the
frequency of the light clunk was never
really happy with this
but Einstein picked it up and ran with
it he applied plunks idea to light
itself saying that light which everybody
knew was a wave is really a stream of
photons each with a discrete amount of
energy Einstein himself called this the
only truly revolutionary thing he did
but it explains the way light shining on
a metal surface
knocks loose electrons even people who
hated the idea had to agree that it
works brilliantly the next puzzle piece
came from Ernest Rutherford in England
in 1909 Ernest Marsden and Hans Geiger
working for Rutherford shot alpha
particles at gold atoms and were stunned
to find that some bounced straight
backwards this showed that most of the
mass of the atom is concentrated in a
tiny nucleus the cartoon atom you learn
in grade school with electrons orbiting
like a miniature
solar system that's Rutherford's there's
one little problem with Rutherford's
atom it can't work classical physics
tells us that an electron whipping
around in a circle emits light and we
use this all the time to generate radio
waves and x-rays Rutherford's atoms
should spray x-rays in all directions
for a brief instant before the electron
spirals in to crash into the nucleus but
Niels Bohr a Danish theoretical
physicist working with Rutherford
pointed out that atoms obviously exist
so maybe the rules of physics needed to
change Bohr proposed that an electron in
certain special orbits doesn't emit any
light at all atoms absorb and emit light
only when electrons change orbits and
the frequency of light depends on the
energy difference in just the way Planck
and Einstein introduced Bohr's adam
fixes Rutherford's problem and explains
why atoms emit only very specific colors
of light each element has its own
special orbits and thus its own unique
set of frequencies the Bohr model has
one tiny problem there's no reason for
those orbits to be special but Louis de
bruit a French PhD student brought
everything full circle he pointed out
that if light which everyone knew is a
wave behaves like a particle
maybe the electron which everyone knew
is a particle behaves like a wave and if
electrons are waves it's easy to explain
Bohr's rule for picking out the special
orbits once you have the idea that
electrons behave like waves you can go
look for it and within a few years
scientists in the US and UK had observed
wave behavior from electrons these days
we have a wonderfully clear
demonstration of this shooting single
electrons at a barrier with slits cut in
it each electron is detected at a
specific place at a specific time like a
particle but when you repeat the
experiment many times all the individual
electrons trace out a pattern of stripes
characteristic of wave behavior the idea
that particles behave like waves and
vice versa is one of the strangest and
most powerful in physics Richard Feynman
famously said that this illustrates the
central mystery of quantum mechanics
everything else follows
like pieces of a puzzle falling into
place